- Okay.
Good afternoon, everyone,
nice to see you all here.
Thank you so much for
coming to our talk today.
My name is Nick,
I lead product management
for cloud security
and exposure managements
here at SentinelOne.
I'm joined by my colleague, Joe.
- Yeah, and my name is Joe Poyner,
I'm a Senior Solutions Engineering
Director at SentinelOne.
- Yeah.
And we wanna talk to you all
today about autonomous SOC;
moving from a collection of tools
to using an autonomous SOC,
and I'd like to lay out
maybe the groundwork for you a little bit.
So, where I'd like to start
is the current challenges
that Security Operations
Centers, or SOCs, face,
what the current attack
landscape actually looks like,
and then how we can leverage generative AI
and agentic workflows
to move to a more
autonomous security model.
And at the end, we'll
tell you a little bit
about how you can get
hands on with these tools
after the presentation,
if you're so interested.
Now, before I get started,
I'm gonna ask you guys a quick question,
make sure everybody's awake.
Has anyone in here ever worked
in a security operations
center, or works in one now?
Okay, more people than I
expected, that's awesome.
So, look, I think those folks know,
and the rest of you are about to learn,
security analyst work is super
unsustainable today, right?
So if you think about the current
sort of security operations
center lifecycle,
it's incredibly manual,
it's incredibly intense.
SOC analysts have to go through
an endless number of alerts,
it can take hours just
to triage those alerts,
and even more time to then
investigate the things
that need to be investigated,
ideally respond to threats
if they do exist in your environments.
And forget ever trying to get
proactive with risk management
and preventing these things from happening
in the first place,
it takes days at the
best of organizations.
So, our mission is to make
this better for all of you.
And we're starting to
do that today with...
Well, actually, before I talk about that,
let's talk about why.
So we can use AI to make those
things better for you all,
and we'll learn that in a second.
But, on the flip side,
while you defenders are hampered
by governance and policies
and maybe even politics
in your organizations,
and org charts,
attackers are not.
They're completely unencumbered,
they can use whatever tools they want,
whenever they want to,
to get the job done,
and we're seeing that
live in the world today.
Google Threat Intelligence
released an interesting report
of new polymorphic malware,
generative AI generated payloads
that are different every single
time the malware executes,
called Prompt FLUX.
I'm sure everyone here probably saw
a very interesting report by Anthropic
about attackers using AI to
automate attacks at scale,
both reconnaissance and initial access.
Now, what I think is so
interesting about that example
is that the attack itself,
if you go read the Anthropic report,
which I highly suggest all of you do
if you're interested in this space,
the attack itself wasn't
particularly special, right?
Find an open port, find
a vulnerable application,
find your way into the environment, right?
These are the types of things
that we all deal with every single day,
humans have been doing them
for many, many, many years.
The special part about this
was that attackers were
able to automate away
90% of the grunt work,
and do this at scale
without ever having a
human touch the keyboard.
And, yes, at the end,
it'll need some adjustment,
some fine-tuning to really drive through
and breach through those environments,
but they're able to zoom out of the grind,
and defenders haven't
been able to do that yet.
- I mean, can you imagine?
You know, I myself,
I use Gen AI to write a lot of my emails,
and it's fantastic for doing that,
I jot down a couple of
sentences and I say,
"Hey, beef this up,
make it look a little
bit more professional."
Who here remembers when you
used to get a spam email
and the way that you would
detect that it was spam
was because of misspellings,
or because of poor grammar?
I mean, we've all seen it,
you know, grandma calls you up and says,
"I think I've been hacked,"
and you see the email and you're like,
"How did you fall for that?"
But we're at the point now with Gen AI,
and attackers can use these tools
rather than us using them for good,
they're using them for evil.
And so, they're coming in
with now emails, images
that are perfectly crafted,
that even somebody like myself
who lives in this day in and day out,
I take a look at one of these
and I can't tell anymore
whether it's spam or whether
it's an actual, valid email.
It's really getting terrifying out there.
- Yeah.
So two pieces here, right?
Generative AI malware, like Prompt FLUX,
or what SentinelLABS found MalTerminal,
which uses GPT-4 to
auto-generate new payloads,
and the automation of processes
at scale, at machine speed,
using AI to do that and
getting rid of the grunt work.
So we're fighting adversaries
that are rewriting their
playbooks every single day,
and ultimately moving
faster than a human can.
So, what do we wanna do about that?
At SentinelOne,
Purple AI is sort of
the engine and the brain
that powers our response to that problem.
It provides not just your normal,
sort of ChatGPT-style
natural language interface,
which it does also do,
but it provides human-level reasoning
inside of the Singularity platform.
It can do auto triage and investigation
like you'll see in a little bit,
Joe's got a cool demo for you all.
It also integrates with
our automation platform,
so it can orchestrate and
take action on your behalf,
and we even run our own proprietary models
that we've trained using
systems like AWS Bedrock.
We have a set of models
called Ultraviolet,
including, you know, even
our machine learning models
to detect malware at the agent-level
and broad threat intelligence
through partnerships
and private feeds internally.
So, AI is going from assisting
you in doing all of this work
to doing all of the work for you
and getting your approval,
suggestions, changes.
And this is a really,
really important change
in the industry, right?
This is how we start to scale
what we can do in response
to the AI age of threats
in the landscape.
So imagine a world
where instead of, you know, an analyst
going through 10,000
alerts in a single day,
which I have seen in real-life before,
you have an AI agent go
through 10,000 alerts
and surface what it thinks
might be the most interesting 500, right?
Imagine a world
where instead of going and
doing all of that work yourself,
you are simply supervising
and managing your virtual team
of AI agentic SOC users.
- What I think is most exciting
about that is, you know,
when I was in college a long time ago
studying to be an analyst,
I had visions of a world
where I was that guy on the keyboard
hunting down attackers, very "CSI" style.
Little did I know that once
I got out in the real-world,
"No, Joe, sit down in this chair,
you've got a queue of
alerts that are coming in,
and you need to handle several
hundred of these alerts
every single day."
If somebody would've told me
that that was what security life was like,
I would've gone and
become a used car salesman
or something else.
Now the industry has been promising
these types of advancements
for a long time,
but we're now finally at the stage
where analysts can stop
being firefighters,
and they can truly transition
into a more strategic role,
like you said, managing these
AIs, doing that grunt work,
being more of that "CSI"
style, you know, threat hunter
rather than just a ticket handler.
- Absolutely.
And you might notice something,
and this may be surprising,
hopefully it's not,
what we're not talking about today
is replacing humans in
the security workflow.
- No.
- I don't believe
that will ever happen.
- Mm-mm.
- What we're talking about
is like leveraging humans
to do what they do best.
Another good example,
I think an analogy that we can use here
is self-driving cars, right?
Has anyone here this week used
the Zoox self-driving taxis?
Okay, you're braver
than I am for sure.
(Joe laughing)
But, look, even when you get in that car,
you still have to tell
it where to go, right?
You're in charge of the mission,
what is the journey that you wanna go on?
And so, we believe humans
are the mission commanders
of the security operations center.
They may not be the boots
on the ground forever,
but they're an absolutely
instrumental part of this forever.
So, we started to talk about
autonomy and self-driving cars.
SentinelOne has come up
with an autonomous SOC
model, Maturity Model,
very similar to like a
self-driving car maturity model.
And, back in the day, we
started at zero, right?
We're writing our own
simple rule detections,
we're doing completely
manual investigation,
and, look, over time in the industry,
this has gotten better.
We moved to having automated playbooks,
we even moved into a world many years ago
of AI-assisted automation, right?
I would actually claim that
when SentinelOne was founded,
it was founded in this Level 2 phase.
We've been using machine learning models
to detect malware at scale
across customer environments,
and we call this static
AI, for many, many years,
it's what the company was born on.
Today, we believe we are at
Level 3: Partial Autonomy,
the ability to reason and
predict potential threats
to create detections and
detect suspicious activity,
and more importantly, start
to go down the second half
of that life cycle, right,
triage, investigation, response.
But it is definitely still
AI is assisting humans,
and not necessarily humans
assisting AI as much yet.
So what's next is what we believe
is high-autonomy, Level 4.
This is where you become
those mission commanders,
and it's what we're building
right now at SentinelOne.
So, autonomous security is already real,
like we said, we are at Level 3,
we have some level of autonomy in the SOC.
And at SentinelOne, what this looks like
is not just at the end of the cycle,
auto triage, investigation,
all those things,
it actually starts at
the very, very beginning.
Security operations center is only as good
as the data that can be pulled
into that security operations center.
And so, we've built, or
acquired, Observo AI,
which helps us pull in the
right data at the right time
in the right ways, right?
We say here, perfect data, zero noise.
I actually think about
this a little differently,
make sure you have all of
the data that you need,
and none that you don't, right?
If any of you have worked in the SOC
and a few of you have,
hunting through meaningless
like security valueless data
as you're trying to go through an incident
is incredibly infuriating.
You already have enough work to do,
now you have 10 times as
much data to sift through,
90% of which is completely
useless during that incident.
So, you wanna pull in
exactly what you need
and nothing that you don't.
We also need to be able
to answer questions
incredibly quickly,
it's why SentinelOne has
made huge performance
and scalability improvements
to our query engine.
We have an industry-leading
query engine and AI SIEM,
and that's gonna be incredibly important
for the agentic and
autonomous SOC as well.
These toolsets don't disappear,
what uses them changes.
So what took humans hours or days to do
will take agentic users
seconds or minutes.
But in order for that to be true,
the query also has to return
at that timescale, right?
It needs to be able to ask the questions
and get the response it needs,
which is why we've built
this massively parallel query engine
as the basis for our
security operations center.
And, finally, because
we have these toolsets,
we plan to offer a bunch of out
of the box agentic workflows
to all of you on our platform,
and Joe's gonna show you
that in just a minute,
but that will be generally applicable
for all users and all organizations
that partner with SentinelOne.
We're at re:Invent,
most of you build stuff,
you're coding, or you're doing low-code,
or maybe you're using things
like cloud-code-to-prototype,
I know I am, I used to
be a software engineer,
they haven't let me touch that
in a really, really long
time for good reason,
but I'm starting to play with it again
in my personal life, and it's really fun.
So, we've also released the
ability to unleash that data
for your own agentic agents and workflows
via our Purple AI MCP server,
and we'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute.
- One of the things that I
like to highlight on this,
because as a Solutions
Engineer-focused person,
I love these slides
that they come up with,
but whenever I see 20X
performance upgrades,
it always makes me a little bit like,
"Well, is that just a number,
or do you really mean it?"
We just ran something
called the SentinelOne
ThreatOps World Championship
where we ran 3,000 people
through a capture the flag exercise,
and I built it, me and my team.
And one of our biggest concerns was...
We had part of our game
where they would have to craft queries,
and we wanted to see how
quickly they could do it.
Our biggest concern was
they would figure out
our cheat code.
Our system is so fast
that you can do star
contains and then a string,
and it won't tip over like a legacy SIEM,
or a legacy data platform,
or take a week to pull back the data.
You can literally do this
across weeks or months of data,
and it'll handle it just fine.
And that's what the 20X
performance upgrade is,
even on inefficient queries like that,
the backend is so strong and so fast
that we were literally concerned
if one of our players figures out
that they don't have to write a query,
they can just do star contains
the thing and find it,
the game would be over.
Luckily, nobody figured it out,
nobody knew our cheat
code, and our game went on,
and it was an absolute success.
- I would love to see an agentic system,
they might take that approach.
But...
(Joe laughing)
Yeah.
So this is what we have today,
this is all available right now.
And so, what does this mean?
Like, let's go back to the
human user for a second.
All of this helps enhance and
accelerate that human user,
right?
So, we start with gaining visibility,
that's getting the data in,
we see 80% reduction in noise,
and a hundred times
faster than legacy SIEMs,
that's what we see in our benchmarking
with our current systems.
And because of that,
we'll have faster, more
real-time detection.
What does it say?
It's a little small for me right now,
but in the 60% range of
detection, efficiency increases.
And because you're able
to detect things faster,
you can move through to
investigation faster,
you can get that done faster as well.
So triage an investigation with Purple AI
and the autonomous SOC,
40% faster than it was
without these tools.
And all of this leads to
just generally a 55% increase
in the ability to respond, remediate,
and move forward, right?
So these have very, very
real efficiency gains
for our users and for organizations,
but it really is still about
that analyst experience.
So, we've talked a little bit
about the analyst experience,
you've seen the sort of like life cycle
from visibility to response,
what are the actual capabilities
in the autonomous SOC
that drive these improvements?
It starts with auto
triage through Purple AI,
helping you surface what you should
or should not care about upfront
out of the large number of like signals
and maybe even large number of detections,
depending on your organization.
We can then help you hunt and investigate
with dynamic agent-based reasoning,
we can even help you enrich
and ask further questions
via our hyper-automation platform.
So something that
actually our internal SOC
at SentinelOne does
is they use agents embedded
in hyper-automation workflows
that not only decide
what questions to ask,
but how to branch to the next
step in the automated workflow
to pull that back and reduce the time
that a human needs to spend
on each individual incident.
And, of course, you have things
like recommended actions,
detection rule creation
as you move towards that more
proactive model of security.
All right, I think this is my
chance to turn it over to Joe
to actually show you, right?
Seeing is believing.
So, let's start to talk
a little bit about this.
- So, let me start with
a very quick story.
Again, what I do, one
of the things that I do,
is I give demonstrations
to people like Forrester and Gartner
where they give us scenarios and they say,
"Joe, we wanna see this thing
live in your environment
and how you interact with it."
And so, I'm setting up
infrastructure for Forrester,
and they say, "Joe, we wanna
start with a phishing email,
then we wanna see a lateral
movement compromise,
and we wanna see all this other stuff."
So what basically happens is,
I have to build hacking infrastructure
in order to show them it's fine.
So what do I do?
I turn to a cloud provider
and I choose Microsoft Azure,
and I say, "Okay,
I'm gonna spin up a
domain called Forrester,
but it's gonna be F0orrester,
and I'm gonna set up a
fake login page for Okta,
that's where my user's gonna go
and be tricked to give
away their credentials.
I set it up,
and the thing only needs to
live for maybe three days.
And I say, Microsoft is gonna catch me,
'cause they're good, they're Microsoft,
but it'll take at least a week, okay?
I'm out in the backyard with my kids,
we're playing on Saturday,
and all of a sudden my phone
rings, and I pull out my phone,
and it's a guy, a famous guy
in our company named JAGS,
his name is Jose Andres
something Guerrero, but-
- [Nick] I'm not gonna butcher it,
but he runs-
- It's-
Our SentinelLabs'
research team-
- Yes.
- [Nick] Here at SentinelOne.
- Literally his name,
everybody just calls him JAGS.
"Why am I getting a call
from JAGS on a Saturday?"
And I pick up the phone,
"Hey, JAGS, what's going on?"
Never talked to the guy before in my life,
I just know he was kind of famous.
And he goes,
"So, Joe, we think your
account has been compromised.
And I'm like, "Oh, that's not good.
You know, what do you need?"
He says, "Well, there's
some hacking infrastructure
in Azure,
we think an attacker is using your account
to create this infrastructure,
and they're impersonating Forrester.
And like we've got all hands on deck,
we're about to nuke your
account from orbit."
And I say, "Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Don't worry, it's not
an attacker, it's me."
And, of course, he goes,
"What do you mean it's you?"
And I say, (imitates muttering)
"Let me explain."
And I explained to him the whole scenario,
and he goes, "Well,
it's a little bit late.
Microsoft has destroyed your
entire environment, it's gone.
Good luck."
And afterwards, I asked him, I said,
"Well, you know, what
was the process for you?"
And it was interesting to see
they got a call from Microsoft,
"One of your employees is compromised,"
he then researches me,
"Does Joe have any alerts
inside of our console?
Has Joe traveled anywhere?
Any potential password compromises?"
And they had four or
five hours worth of work,
four or five hours worth of work
that I feel really bad about, okay,
'cause they didn't need to do it.
Before they called me to say,
"Joe, is this real?"
Four to five hours, it's a
lot of work on a weekend,
I felt really bad.
I sent him a couple of six
packs of beverages for it,
because I felt so bad.
But what we're talking
about with all of this,
with AI, it's no longer four
or five hours on the weekend,
we're talking about the AI
doing all of that work for you,
looking at, "Is Joe Poyner compromised?
Has he received any phishing emails?
Has he gone anywhere suspicious?
Has he been traveling anywhere?"
That's what we're talking about.
So, let me show you.
The very first step is
our agentic AI coming in
and automatically triaging
all of our alerts.
And so, we've got a possible
compromised identity,
and we're gonna tell it
start an investigation.
And what it's going to do,
it's going to process
through the various steps
and not just a static list, okay?
Not a static list of A, B, C, and D,
but a reasoning model,
where it takes a look at it and says,
"Is this a possibility?
No, we've ruled that one out.
Now let's try other possibilities."
And so, what we can see is,
it's conducted the investigation
and then highlighted now
that it needs review.
And this one in particular
is very important,
that we want a human in the loop.
So, we can see, here are
the investigation steps
that it went through,
highlighting things
like initial discovery,
alert analysis, and impact assessment.
And these are all
dynamically-generated and executed.
Now, what this is is that our agentic AI
allows you to do this at scale.
So, if you think about it,
where we were talking
about earlier with JAGS,
my poor, suffering JAGS,
who had to investigate my false positive,
imagine there's not just one alert
on the weekend for Joe
Poyner, but there's 10.
We've now eaten up his entire weekend,
he's now investigating all of these,
and most of them turn out
to be false positives.
He chases them down the rabbit hole,
but then eventually he gets
to Joe Poyner and he says,
"No, it's okay, don't worry about it."
The AI though, we can let the AI churn
on these types of repetitive tasks,
then it'll bring it to us,
and then all we have to do
is make the five minute
decision of yes or no,
we agree or disagree.
So, let's see this in action
where Purple AI kicks
off the investigation
for the impossible traveler alert
that we showed on our first page.
So what it's going to do
is it's going to take a look and say,
"Who is the user?"
We have an impossible traveler alert,
let's take a look at who the user is,
in this case, it's James
Sabala, he's a Cloud Engineer.
We've gone over to Workday,
pulled all of his information,
and we've noted he's logging
in from an unusual location.
So at this point,
Purple AI hypothesizes and says to itself,
"Hey, he's probably had
an account compromise.
So what do we need to do?"
Just like what JAGS did with me,
is he needs to reach out to the end user.
And that's the power of Purple AI
is that it can reach
out via hyper-automation
and ask the end user
whether or not they are
actually compromised.
Now, once we've confirmed with that user,
we wanna go ahead and
review Proofpoint alerts.
We wanna take a look and try and establish
how has that account been compromised?
Was it compromised by
phishing or something else?
If we take a look though,
we also have other pieces of telemetry
that we need to pull together
by querying systems like EDR telemetry,
by looking at other sources like Workday,
or even AWS logs to see
has this user account been
compromised in some other way?
Now, our AI doesn't stop at investigation,
Purple AI agentically surfaces
pre-approved recommended actions
via hyper-automation or automation suite.
So, for example, we can see here,
it's gonna suggest that
we rotate AWS credentials,
block the attacker IP, and
even restrict S3 access,
and, of course, the most important one,
suspend the user in Okta.
Now the last very most important piece
that I personally like is it says,
"Guys, now that we've detected
something in our environment,
we understand how this
attacker potentially works,
let's detect them sooner."
And so, that very last step
that you saw in the video
was one where it asks
to not only take action
on the single user,
but "Let's create a rule
so that any similar
detections down the road
are detected sooner and
understood quicker."
This is the dream, guys,
agentic AI taking away so much work
that we do every single day,
and simply automating it,
and I, for one, welcome
our machine overlords.
(Nick chuckling)
If they wanna take
my boring work away from
me, I say let 'em do it.
- Thanks so much, Joe.
So, look, that went really fast,
and I think that's kind of the point.
But if we think back
to the really painful,
time consuming grind that we
started our presentation with,
that grind has become less
burdensome and more interesting,
something that a human
can really dive into
and use their time effectively.
No more are we doing
endless triage of alerts,
no more are we pouring
through tons of noisy data
in the SIEM,
we're not even necessarily
having to build out
our automation playbooks anymore,
it's all being done by Purple
AI and the autonomous SOC.
So across the entire life cycle, right,
from triage all the way through
to proactive risk management,
we've seen how agentic workflows
can take away the burden
and leave users in control and in command.
So, from frustrated and very frustrated
and hours and days of work,
the SOC analyst life changes;
from hours to minutes, maybe
from minutes to seconds,
from barely keeping up
to always staying ahead,
I think that makes for a happier SOC team,
I'm sure I would feel a lot better
if I wasn't doing 10,000
alerts worth of triage
every single day,
but, most importantly,
I think it helps you
keep your organizations
much, much more secure,
especially in a world where attackers
are trying to leverage the
same types of technologies
in the reverse order, right,
or in the opposite way.
All right.
So, we talked a little
bit about how SentinelOne
is doing this itself,
just as a quick reminder,
you guys are builders,
you may wanna use AI in your own ways,
you may be building your own agents,
or leveraging other models and agents
that exist out in the ecosystem,
we believe that the Singularity platform
and Purple AI enables a
toolset for those agents,
and those agents could
be ours at SentinelOne,
they could also be yours.
This is why we recently launched GA,
our Purple AI MCP server,
it's actually fully open source,
it's available on GitHub today.
So, you know, personally,
what I'm really hoping for
is that I'm gonna go home,
and next week I'm gonna go take a look
and see all of the amazing stuff
that you all have built
on top of Purple AI MCP
using the autonomous SOC
and some of the ideas
that we've talked about
a little bit today.
All right, how can you
use it this week, Joe,
what can we do?
- Oh my gosh, if you wanna see this,
so we've talked about a
lot of really cool stuff,
but if you wanna actually come and see it,
there's a couple of different things.
One, we have The Security Social,
that's an invite-only exclusive event.
If you have been invited,
we hope to see you there.
But one of our cool events that we do
is Mortal vs. Machine.
This is our booth on the expo,
and we have an analyst with
10-plus years of experience,
the guy is good,
and we invite somebody up from
the audience to take him on.
He doesn't get AI, you get AI,
and you have three questions.
So far, we have
demoralized him very badly,
because he's lost a vast
majority of the time,
but it truly does highlight
that somebody with no experience
inside of the SentinelOne platform
can pick up AI and
become as good or better
than somebody with 10 years of experience.
We also have our AWS GameDay
Experience on Thursday,
we welcome any and all to come sign up
where you're going to be
able to play for some prizes
in AWS GameDay,
and see how SentinelOne
and AWS come together
into a cohesive system.
And then AWS on SentinelOne.com;
so we ask if you're interested
in any of this stuff,
please, go out to these
resources, test us,
you know, say,
"You guys said some cool stuff,
let me get my hands on it
to actually prove it out
and see if you mean it."
And I'll just say thank you everybody
for attending our talk today,
and, everybody, have a nice
rest of your conference.
- If you guys have any questions,
please come up and ask,
we'd be happy to answer
them, and I hope you enjoy.
(audience applauding)